hi my name is Charma cochrane assistant
professor in the department of
translational genomics and department of
pediatrics at the Keck School of
Medicine of the University of Southern
California and today I'll be presenting
some of the data that we obtained using
Nano string profiling and a title of
presentation is called transcriptional
profiling of the pediatric osteosarcoma
microenvironment
you
so as an introduction to osteosarcoma as
this is a disease that not too terribly
many people focus on this is the most
common malignant bone tumor in the
pediatric and adolescent young adult age
range Pediatrics being defined as ages
zero through 14 in the adolescent young
adult age range being defined as ages 15
through 39 so as we can see on the graph
on the Left where rate per million is
plotted on the y-axis and age diagnosis
is plotted on the x-axis we can see that
there is a peak during this adolescent
young adult age range in both males and
females and on the right is a gross
depiction of what an osteosarcoma
would look like these tumors do invade
the bone marrow cavity as well often
cases
you
Accio sarcomas are genomically complex
tumors with profound genomic instability
yet very few single nucleotide variants
so here we can actually see the rate of
chromothripsis in osteosarcoma which is
a catastrophic genomic event where a
specific genomic locus is actually
shattered and then recombined in a
random order and that resulted massive
rearrangements of the affected locus so
this is just on the left hand side this
is whole genome sequencing that was
performed from a patient with metastatic
osteosarcoma and the colored lines Criss
crossing the inside of this circo's plot
represent inter and intra chromosomal
translocations so massive amounts of
structural abnormalities on the right
hand side is data from a recent article
and just showing out of various
pediatric tumors solid tumors CNS and
hematologic malignancies osteosarcoma x'
exhibit the highest number of structural
variants and prevalent chromothripsis
unfortunately the survival rates for
patients diagnosed with osteosarcoma
have not improved over the last 30 years
patients with metastatic disease do
demonstrate an inferior outcome as
indicated by the survival plots
underneath on the left is the survival
plot looking at patients with localized
disease ik diagnoses on the right is the
survival plot looking at patients with
metastatic disease at diagnosis the
solid red line indicates patient
indicates overall survival whereas the
dotted blue line indicates event-free
survival and what we can see is that
patients with metastatic disease that
diagnosis have that they have a
relatively dismal prognosis
data from different clinical trials
shows that immune checkpoint blockade
does not provide the therapeutic benefit
to patients with advanced or and/or
metastatic disease
then we asked a relatively simple
question does the genomic complexity of
osteosarcoma facilitated immune escape
and or resistance to immunotherapy so
right around the time we were starting
to ask this question a paper came out
and was very instrumental in helping us
guide our our thought process so on the
Left we can see that osteosarcoma is
have a variety of different copy number
alterations whether they be focal events
or events encompassing chromosome arms
or whole chromosomes on the right this
paper demonstrates that focal copy
number events have one tend to have one
outcome in sustaining proliferation a
chromosome arm or entire chromosome copy
number alterations can lead to sustained
proliferation or scaping the immune
system and then the concept of neo
antigen load as well can actually
present targets cancer specific targets
for T cells to recognize so we know that
osteosarcoma is Denys demonstrate
aneuploidy these focal and broad copy
number alterations and osteosarcoma do
generate neo epitopes albee it at a much
lower level than that of most adult
solid tumors and the expression of these
neo epitopes is very low so putting this
all together we decided to ask the
question are there copy number
alterations whether they be focal whole
chromosome arms or whole chromosomes but
are there copy alteration copy number
alterations in osteosarcoma that will
impact the ability of these tumors to be
recognized by the immune system
in doing so we that we found that there
are actually copy number game of
targetable immune checkpoint sin in
subsets of patients with osteosarcoma so
here on the top we can see circo's plots
so this is a means by which we can
represent whole genome sequencing data
and on the left the PDL 1 po2 locus is
amplified on in the middle the b7 h3 or
CD 276 locus is gained and on the right
the locus and coding ideal one is also
amplified the angka print on the bottom
just shows how these the distribution of
these of these events such that the PDL
1p l 2 locus is actually a shared locus
and there is tremendous overlap between
them the b7 h3 locus and the ideal one
locus or different low size so what we
can see is that there are non
overlapping subsets of osteosarcoma z'
that have copy number gains or
amplifications of different target
immune checkpoint genes
however
understanding or demonstrating that
there are copy number alterations in
targetable targetable immune checkpoint
genes in osteosarcoma is profound in
that we were the first to discover this
and this provides a context for
therapeutic intervention however this
does not these tumours do not grow in a
vacuum we have to understand the micro
environment that these tumors grow in so
how do these copy number alterations
impact the tumor micro-environment
and at the same time how does the tumor
microenvironment impact the growth
progression and clonal selection and
expansion of these tumors one thing I do
want to note is the very interesting
micro environment of osteosarcoma so
these are indeed bone tumours oftentimes
which invade the bone marrow the bone
marrow is the site of postnatal
hematopoiesis so you one can imagine
that these osteosarcoma cells that
invade the bone marrow are in the
presence of various immature immune
cells and progenitor cells so this
provoked this presents a very
interesting type of micro environment so
we wanted to ask the question what does
the micro environment of osteosarcoma
look like in primary disease meaning
tumors of the bone and in metastatic
disease and specifically our lung
metastasis
so to do that we utilize a tissue bank
at Children's Hospital of Los Angeles
and we retrieved pediatric osteosarcoma
specimens these specimens were
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded blocks
these were unmatched samples so we have
a subset of samples that were obtained
from the lung representing pulmonary
metastasis and then another subset of
samples that were obtained from the
actual primary bone tumor this chart
demonstrates the
demonstrates the
sample
is charged up this chart demonstrates
the B or characterizes the samples that
were actually used for this study so we
can see age sex the site from which the
tumor was derived or the specimen to
drive the pathological staging and the
disease status so these tumors are
indeed bone tumors which means that they
are heavily calcified so in order to
actually cut sections from these blocks
we had the block's acid decalcified both
the metastatic and non-metastatic
specimens were acid decalcified such
that the there was no batch effects due
to one set of specimens being too
calcified and the others not being too
calcified so the tumor sections the
tumor specimens were cut into serial
sections a portion of the special of
those specimens were scraped and the RNA
was extracted from these samples he's in
the Agincourt form of pure RNA get the
RNA from these samples was then utilized
for the gene expression profiling using
the nano string pan-cancer io 360 panel
the remaining sections were used for
tissue staining namely hematoxylin eosin
and immunohistochemical analysis
the IHC Hz and gene expression data was
a combined analyze and integrity
integrated and interpreted such that we
can really understand what is going on
at the gene expression level and the
protein level in the tumor
micro-environment of metastatic and
non-metastatic osteosarcoma
one thing I do want to note is that the
specimens used for this study came from
patients who responded poorly to
chemotherapy this is important because
in the clinical setting patients with
osteosarcoma that would have received
any kind of immunotherapy would have
already failed the standard of care
chemotherapy so we wanted to ensure that
we were looking and investigating the
tumor micro-environment
in the right context of patients who
have failed prior chemotherapy regimens
we did assess tumor viability prior to
experimentation to ensure that we
weren't utilizing specimens that had
extensive necrosis so all of the
specimens that were used had sufficient
viable tumor to go on for downstream
analysis
given the fact that the io 360 panel is
really focused on a hybrid captured
hybrid capture approach of capturing
mRNA for subsequent counting we needed
to ensure that the RNA that we had was
of sufficient quality this is extremely
important given the fact that all of the
samples were asked to be calcified and
acid will heavily degrade nucleic acids
so what we can see here is that for all
of the specimen we had sufficient
concentration of nucleic acid and these
nucleic acid species were 300
nucleotides in length or greater as
indicated by the % DV 300 value so this
gave us confidence that the nucleic
acids that were extracted were
sufficient for going into the Nano
string not a string io 360 profiling on
the right is a trace from the
agilent tape station 4200 just showing
what the distribution of nucleic acid
molecules actually looks like at the
bottom it is the nucleotide size and
length so we can see that there is a
sufficient number of molecules that RNA
RNA molecules that is of sufficient size
but now present the results from this
man on string profiling so the first
thing that we wanted to do was to get an
overall view of what the profiles look
like between metastatic and
non-metastatic osteosarcoma
so we performed an unsupervised
hierarchical clustering and what we can
see is that this clustering separates
the metastatic and non-metastatic
osteosarcoma specimens into two distinct
and non overlapping clusters whereas the
metastatic osteosarcoma specimens are
labeled in gray at the bar on the top
and the non-metastatic osteosarcoma
specimens are labeled in black and again
the bar at the top
this color convention gray indicating
metastatic and black indicating
non-metastatic osteosarcoma are is
consistent throughout this presentation
next we looked at the expression levels
of various inhibitory and stimulatory
immune checkpoints and for the most part
what we can see is that the
non-metastatic specimen
have higher expression of various immune
checkpoints in comparison to the
metastatic specimens there are three
notable exceptions one of them being hvm
or TNS RSF 14 in which the metastatic
specimens have higher expression than
the non-metastatic specimens the same
can be said for PDL 1 and the bottom
left hand corner of the panel and as
well as for vista which is the bottom
row second from the right so with the
exception of these three checkpoints
the expression of various immune
checkpoints is greater in the
non-metastatic specimens versus the
metastatic specimens
we then looked at a variety of
functional meta gene signatures and this
is one of the strengths of the assay in
which there are a collection of
functional metagenes signatures that
describe different processes within the
tumor in the tumor microenvironment in
this heat map the functional meta gene
signatures are on the left and on the
right hand side of the heat map are the
genes and gene signatures that comprise
each of the functional meta-gene
signatures again hierarchical
unsupervised hierarchical clustering
separates the metastatic and
non-metastatic osteosarcoma specimens
into two distinct clusters that do not
overlap we then want to look at the just
be able to apply statistics and see if
there are any statistically significant
differences between these different
functional meta gene signatures and in
metastatic and non-metastatic
osteosarcoma 's and what we can see is
that the metastatic specimens
demonstrate a decrease in Richmond in
these functional gene signatures when
compared to non metastatic specimens I
do want to point your attention to the
bottom right-hand side of the panel
where we're looking at immune cell
population abundance this was one of the
most interesting findings that we that
we observed and this is what we decided
to follow
so we took that those differences in
immune cell population abundance and
starts to look at the different immune
cell subsets that are described in the
nano string panel and looking at their
relative abundance between metastatic
and non-metastatic osteosarcoma
specimens and what we can see here with
the exception of mast cells the
metastatic osteosarcoma specimens again
in gray contain fewer immune cells than
the non-metastatic osteosarcoma
specimens
this was incredibly important as this
concept of lymphocyte exclusion has
gained a lot of traction recently where
there may indeed be immune cells present
armed however they the localization of
the immune cells is such that the cells
do not actually penetrate the tumor as
opposed to being confined to the
periphery of the of the lesions or not
present at all
in order to visualize the distribution
and localization of t-cells we utilized
immunohistochemistry we specifically
stained for CD 3 epsilon 2
indiscriminately visualize all t-cell
subsets so in this instance we were foot
we were more interested in understanding
all of the art we were more interested
in being able to visualize all t-cell
subsets without respect to whether these
are cd4 cd8 th1 th2 T regs so on and so
forth the top row is hematoxylin and
eosin staining for the sake of
demonstrating that the regions that we
were looking at were did indeed contain
viable tumor
the middle row
shows cd3 epsilon amino reactivity
whereas on the Left we're looking at the
metastatic osteosarcoma specimens
specifically on the periphery of the
tumor adjacent so the normal lung
parenchyma butting up against the actual
metastatic lesion
the middle panel is an image from the
core of that same metastatic lesion on
the right we are looking at the core of
a non-metastatic osteosarcoma the box is
in each one of these panels is just a
region of interest that is further
magnified in the bottom row so what we
can see is that the in the metastatic
osteosarcoma specimens td3 Amino
reactivity is confined to the periphery
of the specimen and we do not see cd3
material activity in the core of the
specimen however in the non-metastatic
osteosarcoma is we do indeed see td3
immuno reactivity
distributed throughout the core of the
tumor on the right hand side we quantify
this immune reactivity and what we can
see is that the non-metastatic specimens
Express
higher levels of cd3 immune reactivity
and this is consistent with the nano
string gene expression profiling data I
do want to note that although the
non-metastatic specimens have more
t-cells that infiltrate the tumor the
abundance of these tumor infiltrating
t-cells is still relatively low in
comparison to a variety of other solid
tumors that arm such as lung cancer or
so on and so forth
now we wanted to look at the activation
status of some of these t-cells so we've
already seen that for one BB expression
is lower in the metastatic versus non
metastatic specimens and we can see that
here on the bottom right-hand side we
can see that for one BB expression and
the metastatic specimens which is
indicated in gray is lower than that of
the non-metastatic specimens indicated
in black
and we then did a correlation analysis
to get an idea of does the expression of
4:1 BB correlate with the abundance of a
variety of lymphocytes now we chose for
one BB because this is an activation
induced co-stimulatory molecules that
serves as a surrogate for lymphocyte and
k cell activation so in doing this
correlation analysis what we can see is
that in the metastatic osteo so in
metastatic osteosarcoma specimens we do
not see a significant correlation
between 4:1 BB expression and the
lymphocyte and NK cell populations
listed however in the non-metastatic in
the non-metastatic osteosarcoma
specimens we do see very very very
strong correlations indicative of
activation status of these lymphocyte
populations
you
going back to this concept of lymphocyte
exclusion our data shows that in the
metastatic osteosarcoma is the T cells
are actually confined to the periphery
and when we start looking at this a
little bit further one of the things we
realize is that angiogenesis can also be
a key mediator to lymphocyte exclusion
whereas the phenotype and and
functionality of the tumor vasculature
can actively prevent T cells from either
extravasated or render the T cells that
do extravasated due to a variety of
different immune checkpoint and immune
checkpoints expressed on the surface of
the endothelial cells we can see b7 h3
also it's been shown that I do 1 + PDL
one have also been expressed on the
vasculature from the endothelial cell
surface of tumor vasculature
so the first thing we wanted to do is to
look at the endothelial cells using the
Nano string data so we chose we chose be
selecting two as a surrogate marker for
activation a selecting is expressed
exclusively in endothelial cells and
it's transcriptionally up regulated in
response to inflammation so this serves
as a marker of an activated and
functional endothelial there are a
variety of other markers such as I cam
one and p-chem one that people often use
however both I cam 1 and P cam one can
actually be expressed in both
endothelial cells and tumor cells
whereas be selected encoded by L II is
specific to endothelial cells so what we
see is that the metastatic osteosarcoma
specimens Express lower levels of eise
elected in comparison to the
non-metastatic osteosarcoma specimens in
black
we wanted to assess the endothelial cell
abundance to determine if the difference
is in ISA lectin was due to a decrease
in tumor vascularity so in assessing the
endothelial cell abundance between
metastatic and non-metastatic
osteosarcoma is what we see is that
there is no significant difference
between between metastatic and
non-metastatic osteo suggesting that the
selecting or the difference is in a
selected between the two groups of
specimens is not due to a decrease or
increase in endothelial cells
the Pearson correlation analysis between
the endothelial cell abundance and a
selected expression in both metastatic
and non-metastatic specimens the bottom
left we can see that there is a strong
correlation between endothelial cell
abundance and a selected expression in
the non-metastatic osteosarcoma
whereas on the bottom right this same
analysis reveals that there is not a
strong correlation between endothelial
cell abundance and East Latin expression
in the metastatic osteosarcoma specimens
suggesting that the cells these
endothelial cells in the metastatic
tumors are hypo responses
next we wanted to investigate a vascular
instability in the context of metastatic
and non metastatic disease
Andrew eaten one and and repeat to our
opposing Li regulate vessel
stabilization and angiogenesis such that
expression of ang one facilitates
parasite coverage vessel maturity and
Vascular stabilization whereas
expression of Andrew queen two induces
parasite detachment and vascular
instability and this is what the diagram
indicates and one is an agonist of the
ty two receptor whereas an Shu is an
antagonist of the ty two receptors so
these two molecules the balance of these
two molecules in binding to tie two
dictates to a large degree the stability
of the vasculature
we queried edge one an inch to
expression in metastatic and
non-metastatic osteosarcoma specimens
and what we can see is that
there's decrease in ange1 in metastatic
osteosarcoma specimens in gray in
comparison to non-metastatic
osteosarcoma specimens there is no there
are no differences between n2 expression
in metastatic and non-metastatic
osteosarcoma
we then calculated the end to two and
one ratio to serve as a surrogate for
vessel stabilization where an increased
ratio favours vascular destabilization
while a decreased ratio favored parasite
coverage best vessel stability and
vessel maturation what we can see here
is that the metastatic osteosarcoma
specimens indicated in gray have an
increase in two to end one ratio in
comparison to that of the non-metastatic
osteosarcoma specimens and what this
shows is that or what this indicates or
suggests is that the vessels in the
metastatic specimens are unstable
we then looked at the ratio the amp
should end one ratio as again as a
surrogate for vascular instability and
correlated this with lymphocyte
abundance in metastatic and not
metastatic osteosarcoma so what we can
see is that in the context of metastatic
disease
the ang 2 + 1 ratio inversely correlates
with inversely correlates with
lymphocyte abundance these correlations
don't these significant correlations do
not exist in my Lloyd and granule acidic
lineage cells and the non-metastatic
osteosarcoma is we do not observe
inverse or or positive correlations
between n 2 and 1 ratio and lymphocyte
or immune cell abundance suggesting that
the metastatic osteosarcoma specimens
are actively associated with lymphocyte
exclusion and that this is this
correlates with vascular instability as
assessed by the inch to 2 + 1 ratio
we also looked at veg F expression in
metastatic and non-metastatic
osteosarcoma
pathophysiological levels of veg F can
induce endothelial cell dysfunction and
is associated with vascular instability
and resistance to anti pd-1 therapy so
on the top row what we can see is veg f
veg of a immuno reactivity in three
different metastatic osteosarcoma x' and
on the bottom the bottom row illustrates
veg fa expression in three different
non-metastatic osteosarcoma so we can
see clearly that the metastatic
osteosarcoma specimens Express higher
levels of bed rest
then the non-metastatic osteosarcoma
specimens and this is quantified on the
right on the top right its
quantification of the veg FA
immunohistochemistry on the bottom right
is a quantification of veg sa gene
expression using the Nano string
profiling and what we can see is that
the trends are the same where metastatic
osteosarcoma has expressed higher
protein and mRNA levels of veg FA in
comparison to non-metastatic specimens
and in both cases these results are
statistically significant
similar to what we did before with the
end to an end 1 ratio we decided to
perform correlation analyses between veg
F and lymphocyte abundance
we see very very similar results to what
we saw previously with the age to two
ends one ratio comparison where veg F
inversely correlates with lymphocyte
abundant in the context of metastatic
disease whereas in non metastatic
disease these correlations do not exist
the next thing that we actually wanted
to look at was the tumor inflammation
signature so the tumor inflammation
signature is a weighted meta-gene
signature that measures the degree to
which the pre-existing anti tumor
adaptive immune response is suppressed
given the fact that we see decreased
abundance of various immune cells in the
metastatic osteosarcoma specimens we
were expecting that the tumour
inflammation signature would actually
demonstrate that
first thing that we did was to look at
the tumor inflammation signature across
various pediatric malignancies just to
gain context as to what the tumor
information signature in osteosarcoma
looks like in comparison to various
other tumors starting from the left we
have retinal blastoma medulloblastoma
adrenocortical tumors Wilms tumors
ependymomas high-grade gliomas forehead
plexus carcinomas t-cell acute
lymphoblastic leukemias low-grade
gliomas rhabdomyosarcoma x' mixed
lineage leukemias neuroblastoma b-cell
acute lymphoblastic leukemia
osteosarcoma cute myeloid leukemia and
melanoma and what we can see is that
osteosarcoma actually has a relatively
high tumor inflammation signature in
comparison to various other pediatric
tumors this data was obtained using the
st. Jude data set when we then look at
the target osteosarcoma data set and
separate specimens into metastatic and
non-metastatic what we see is that the
tumor inflammation score does not differ
between metastatic and non-metastatic
specimens
we did the same analysis with the
specimens used in our study and we see
the same results that the metastatic and
non-metastatic specimens do not differ
as when it comes to the tumor
inflammations again signature of the
tumor information score
from this we were left with a hypothesis
that we're currently trying to validate
such that there are differential roles
in the tumor vasculature in the context
of metastatic and non-metastatic
osteosarcoma so on the left what we
hypothesize is going on in
non-metastatic specimens is that
lymphocytes are actually able to
extravasated a believe the vasculature
and infiltrate the tumor and this is due
to an increased expression of adhesion
molecules and a much more balanced ratio
between veg F + 1 + + 2 however in the
context of metastatic metastatic
osteosarcoma the lymphocytes are
actually excluded and this is mediated
by a decrease in adhesion molecules and
an imbalance between n CH 2 and ang 1
and an increase of veg s signaling
the conclusions from the study are the
following first non-metastatic
osteosarcoma specimens demonstrate
increased beam expression levels of
several immunotherapy to targets whether
they be agonistic or inhibitory
metastatic Austria sarcomas contain
fewer immune cells than the
non-metastatic specimens
and that T cells are actually excluded
from infiltrating the metastatic foci
and are likely hypo responsive or
inactive
the vasculature in metastatic disease
exhibits signs of dysfunction and this
inversely correlates with lymphocyte
abundance in the context of metastatic
osteosarcoma and interestingly the tumor
inflammation score does not differ
between metastatic and non-metastatic
osteosarcoma specimens
the implications for research are the
following first vascular dysfunction and
we assess that using the inch 2 and 1
ratio and expression of a selected
vascular dysfunction actively promotes
lymphocyte exclusion in metastatic
disease in the context of inflammation
such as that is malignancy excessive veg
s signaling can actually induce
endothelial cell energy and this is this
is a state which the endothelial cells
are hypo responsive and do not respond
well to inflammatory sick stimuli and
redistribute the adhesion molecules
and/or down-regulate selective adhesion
molecules the end result being that
lymphocytes are not able to bind the
luminal surface of the vasculature and
extrapolate so we feel that we have
evidence to suggest that this actually
may be occurring in metastatic disease
- we would normalization has become
incredibly
Preda bleep opulent IRMS of targeting
veg Efrain am shoe signaling and this
transient vascular normalization can
actually increase lymphocyte
infiltration and there are several
trials right now that are combining
anti-angiogenic and immune checkpoints
to see if the vasculature can indeed be
stabilized to allow for immune cells to
leave the vasculature infiltrate the
tumors and then relieve that inhibition
using checkpoints
the tumor inflammation signature may not
accurately reflect the biology of
pediatric osteosarcoma and the reason
that we say this is that
CEO sarcomas are a pediatric malignancy
of Mezen mesenchymal origin and the
tumor inflammation score was actually
derived from adult carcinomas so these
differences may actually reflect the
fact that the tumor inflammation score
may be better suited towards specific
types of malignancies and not well
suited towards pediatric medicine common
base malignancies such as that is
osteosarcoma
so I thank you for your time and if you
have any questions please feel free to
send an email and I will get back I will
respond to these questions at my
earliest convenience thank you